Okay, Michael. Which of these two decision trees is smaller?
>> [LAUGH] The one on the right is smaller.
>> That's exactly right because it's easier, it's,
it's easier to represent it in sort of almost
any obvious way that you could think of. It
has fewer nodes, so smaller decision trees, trees with
fewer nodes, less depth, whatever you need to
make it smaller, have smaller lengths than bigger decision
trees. So that means that if all we cared
about was the second term here. We would prefer
smaller decision trees, over bigger decisions trees.
>> Which we do.
>> Which we do. Now what about this over here? The, what
does it mean? So this is pretty straight forward. You got this right?
>> That the length of. Well, I mean guess
what's weird that you, you're kind of moving back and
forth between a notion of a prior, which is
where the p of h came from and a notion
of Well, you know, if we're going to actually have
to describe the hypothesis you're going to have to write
it down in some way, and this gives you
a way of measuring how long it takes to write
it down. But I guess what this whole derivation
is doing is linking those two concepts, so that
you can think about our bias for shorter decision
trees as actually being the prior, right? Actually being the
thing that says the smaller ones are more likely
And vica versa, that when we think about things that
are priors, that are assigning higher probability to certain
things, it's kind of like giving them a shorter description.
>> Right, so infact if you were to take
this example literally here, that we prefer smaller trees
to bigger trees, this kind of a bayesian argument for occam's razor.
>> And pruning.
>> And pruning. Well, you, often use
razors to prune, so it makes perfect sense.
>> Ok, so this is kind of straight foreward, that basically smaller
trees are smaller than bigger trees. It sort of makes sense.
Now, what about this over here? What does it mean to
talk about the length of the data given a particular hypothesis.
>> Uh...I could think of one interpretation there. So
like, if the hypothesis generates the data really well, then
you don't really need the data at all, right?
You just have...you already have the hypothesis. The data is
free. Right? But if it deviates a lot from
the hypothesis, then you're going to have to have a long
description of where the deviations are. So maybe it's kind of
capturing this sort of notion of how well it fits.
>> Right, that's exactly right. So I like that
explanation so let me write it down. So here
we literally just mean something like size of h.
But over here we are talking about, well sort
of error right? if the hypo, if just exactly what
you said if the hypothesis perfectly describes the data,
then you don't need any of the data. But let's
imagine that the hypothesis gets all of the data
labels wrong. Then when you send the hypothesis over To
this person. This, this sort of person we're making up
who, trying to understand the Daden hypothesis. And you're also
going to have to send over what all the correct answers
were. So, what this really is, is a notion of miss-classification
error, or just error in general. If we're thinking about
regression. So, basically, what we're saying is, if we're trying
to find the maximum a posteriori Hypothesis. We want to maximize this
expression. We want to find the h that maximizes this expression.
That's the same as finding the h that
maximizes the log of that expression, which gives you
this. Which is the same as minimizing this expression,
which is just maximizing this expression but throwing a
minus one in front But these terms actually have meanings in information theory,
the best hypothesis, the hypothesis with the maximum a posteriori probability is
the one that minimizes error and the size of your hypothesis.
You want the most simple hypothesis that minimizes
your error. That is pretty much literally occam's razor.
What is important here In reality is that
these are often traded off of one another.
If I give a more complicated or bigger
hypothesis, I can typically drive down my error.
Or I can have a little bit of error for a smaller hypothesis. But this is the
sort of fundamental tradeoff here. You want to find The simplest
hypothesis that still explains your data, that is, minimizes your error.
>> Hm.
>> So this actually has a name, and
that is the minimum description, and there have
been many algorithms over the years that have
tried to do this directly by simply trading
off some notion of error, and some notion
of size. And finding the tradeoff between them
that actually works. Now, if you think about
it for a little whiel Michael you'll realize that
yea this sort of makes sense at the hand wavy level
at which I just talked about it. But, you do have some
real issues here about for example units. So, I don't know if
the units of the size of the hypothesis are directly comparable to
the counts of errors or you know sum of squared errors
or something like that and so you have to come up with
some way of translating between them... And some way of making the
decision whether you would rather minimize this or you'd rather minimize that
if you were forced to make a decision. But the
basic idea is still the same here. That the best
hypothesis is the one that minimizes error without paying too
much of a price for the complexity of the hypothesis.
>> Wow. So I've been sitting here thinking about, so with decision trees,
this notion of length feels... Like you could translate it directly into bits
right like you actually had to write it down and transmit it, it
makes a lot of sense. But then I was thinking about neural networks.
And, and, and given that a fixed neural network architecture it's always
the same number of weights and they're just numbers. So you just
transmit those numbers. So I thought, hmmm, this isn't really helping us
understand? ? ? ? ? ? and then it occurred to me
that those weights, if they get really you're going to need more
bits to express those big weights. And in fact that's exactly when
we get over fitting with neural nets if we let the weights
get too big. So like this gives a really nice story for understanding
neural nets as well.
>> Right. That the complexity is not in the number of parameters
directly but in what you need to represent the value of the parameters.
>> Wow.
>> So I could have ten parameters that are all
binary, in which case I need ten bits. Or they
could be arbitrary real numbers, in which case I might
need, well, an arbitrary number of bits. That's really weird.
>> Yeah, but the point here, Michael, I want to wrap this
up. The point here is we've now used Bayesian learning to derive
a bunch of different things that we've actually been using
all along, and so again the beauty of Bayesian learning is
that it gives you a sort of handle on why
you might be making some of the decisions that you're making.
>> It seems like this raises the theory question
that you threw at me in a previous unit. Right.
Which is like well so if it doesn't really tell
us anything we didn't already know, how important is it?
>> Well in this case, I think it is important
because it told us something that we were thinking and tells
us in fact we were right. So now we can
comfortably go out in the world minimizing some of squared
error when we're in a world where there is some
kind of Gaussian transmission noise. We can go about trying to
Believe Occam's Razor because Bayes told us so. [LAUGH] Thanks
to Shannon. And so on and so forth. We can
do these things and know that in some sense, they're
the right things to do, at least in a Bayesian sense.
>> Neat.
>> Okay, good. Now one more thing, Michael, I'm going to show you.
Which is that everything I've told you so far is a lie. [SOUND]